thank you so much Emily and me Paul
Perry and everyone who has helped make
this conference possible there are many
there are many people that you'll hear
about there's some people supporting the
conference also have exhibit tables such
as clear view silver Hill I want to say
a few quick words my professional career
focuses on this disorder including
direct clinical work training is a major
piece of it research and I have such
mixed emotions today and coming into
this conference because on one hand this
can't the the work I do fills me with
satisfaction that there's help that be
offered that people's lives improve I'm
a DBT provider we focus on helping
people have a life worth living and I
get to see people move toward that and
it just fills me with with a real sense
of purpose in terms of how I spend my
time what I devote myself to and this
conference fills me with joy and pride
just that just the fact that it's it's
grown in so many ways and our focus is
the dark flipside of of the disorder
which is the risk of self-destructive
behaviors in particular suicide and I'm
absolutely not only is it something that
fills us all with with fear I am
completely horrified by the state of
affairs with regard to access to
services for borderline specifically but
also in terms of mental health systems
that are not keeping up with the best
science with the best practices that are
clearly defined and you'll be hearing
about these things today you
hearing about just how far the science
is progressing and things that could be
brought into practice and need to be
much more consistently brought in I'm
also horrified by the grossly inadequate
funding that borderline gets in terms of
research there's wonderful research
you're going to hear about it the
reality is is that if there was anywhere
close to adequate funding for this
disorder there would be so many more
researchers so many more large studies
so many more young investigators who get
who develop a love for serving this
population who won't get turned away
from going for theirs their initial
grants their initial training grants
Young Investigator grants to to pursue
this direction they actually get steered
away from working with this population
with borderline personality disorder and
and it doesn't make any sense and so I
think this is is extremely important for
us to learn about but get involved with
another thing I have I'm going to come
back to that just a moment another thing
I have very mixed emotions about coming
into this conference involves one of my
co directors Emily Ansel who is one of
my one of my most you know for me
colleagues that that I respect esteem I
have been so happy to collaborate with
her in a number of ways including this
conference where I initially invited her
to help out and she is so busy also
someone who devotes herself to research
related to these these issues but she
did because she believed in the cause
and she got more and more involved and
particularly over the last three years
really became the leader of the
conference you know so I I've been
devoted to this for the last 12 years
quite honestly she's the one who put
this conference together and made it
what you'll be seeing today you know
I've supported and we've worked together
but she's she's really done
and because she is as as incredible as
she is at what she does
we are losing her here at Yale she's
been recruited to Syracuse University
where they are having her come in
immediately as a as a tenured associate
professor where she's going to put
together her research program which will
grow and she will get to develop young
investigators in a graduate program and
and so I'm thrilled for her I am nearly
devastated at the loss so the conference
will go on we will be here we are
already planning for next year and but I
really you know so so I do want to
actually just get a hand to Emily thank
you thank you for doing
[Applause]
okay coming back thank you coming back
to the state of affairs you all have
elected to spend your day with us today
and yeah it already indicates that this
is on your radar that you see these
issues of suicide born line
personalities sort of as important and
yet coming to this conference is not
nearly enough and there's lots of
research showing that going and getting
some ideas at a conference doesn't
actually change very much unfortunately
unless you do two things you apply what
you learn you take it into your
workplace you take it to your personal
relationships you find ways to
incorporate what's offered I see people
a standing aisle some of you or
volunteers but I think other people are
got caught in the rain I'm gonna
encourage you if you'd like to find a
seat I think people be understanding
otherwise you know but definitely do so
before we get to our first speaker there
are definitely lots of seats available
if you're on me the the exit row you
know the aisles and you like an aisle
maybe you can move in for now and then
kind of switch back later if that helps
people we don't have a central aisle
okay getting back to what I was saying
there's two things that you need to do
and one is you need to apply what you
learn I'm gonna I'll get there very
quickly there's be lots of tips lots of
suggestions lots of things I want to
highlight one that I'm incorporating
which at this point which is Barbara
Stanley's safety plan that you'll be
hearing about everyone needs to know
what this is everyone needs to be
prepared to either apply this in your
clinical work or know about it if you're
a family member or you are someone who
has lived experience and struggles with
suicide it's a simple document that can
make a big difference so please attend
to it and use it download it get it use
it so that's what only one simple
example
the other thing is another thing we need
to do is we need to address a cold irony
of this disorder which is that
individuals with borderline personality
disorder struggle with self-destructive
behaviors are painfully aware of how
that effects everyone around them how it
affects particularly the people they
love and they tend to feel intense shame
and and don't know what to do with with
the burden the emotional burden the
financial burden that they create and
dr. Thomas joiner has identified that
that feeling of burden itself becomes a
huge risk factor for suicide so again we
need to figure out how can we support
individuals in getting the help they
need how can we assure them that we are
accepting of them where they are as best
they can how can we get the support we
need ourselves and assure them that
we're doing that so I will encourage you
to look for ways to do all of those
things to get the support to give the
reassurance to give the acceptance to be
involved which we've learned and Perry
Hoffman did the research showing that
getting involved with their care helps
them but get involved in a way that
shows that that you are also taking care
of yourself and not and they're not
creating an undue burden so these are
these are very big issues the final
thing I will say and I know we're
getting a little behind our time is we
must get involved with issues of
advocacy we need to get our voices out
there there is a simple way that you're
going to hear about which involves one
of our tables the emotions matter table
you'll you'll meet if you go there I
encourage you to meet Paula to see on
Ieng and and maybe you could hear about
her story but she can help you and
Emily's going to show you how
to sign their petition - ni m h ni MH
get everyone you know to sign the
petition so we can get some funding that
that is is at all consistent with the
amount of devastation that occurs from
these problems and needs to be addressed
to people's devastation to people's
lives get involved in that way there is
a walk to raise awareness for borderline
in New York tomorrow if you can't get
there tomorrow be there next year learn
about that again at that table and
that's it
so so thank you for being here thank you
for your attention today and and I hope
to see you again in future years
[Applause]
[Music]